ti's relationship with deja what is the
biggest
change that you've seen in him he's just
being a little more
understanding he knew that the rest of
the world didn't accept it
and didn't wasn't on his side and they
were very angry
but the only thing it really cares about
is what she feels
tiny it is always so nice to see your
face how are you doing
i'm doing great how are you i'm really
good because
the mix is back on fox soul welcome back
to the mix guys
it is such a cool concept tell me how
did you come up with this idea i was
sitting around with zionique and reggie
nay and just listening to how they had
so many views and
conversations about different things and
i felt like
this is a show this is something that
people need to hear
there needs to be a platform to where
they can speak
their minds speak their truth and um
and be heard are any topics off limits
no we want to talk about everything
whether it's
politics sex uh relationship abuse
drugs we need to be able to speak on all
topics
so we can speak to those who need to be
spoken
last time i spoke with you tiny um it
was right before the new season
of friends and family hustle was about
to premiere
and since then you celebrated your
10-year wedding anniversary how are you
guys doing
we've um we've just been through like
the
ups and downs and we've been through you
know sometimes you fall in and out of
love we've done all of that
but we we've been able to come back much
stronger
as a unit i think it's just all because
we really have a genuine love and desire
and we we actually are very attracted to
one another
sexually and i think that what keeps us
strong together
at two years in i was like i don't think
i'm gonna make it to three my
second year was like really really rough
and then we got to the third year and it
got a little better but got a little
rough again
so i was like i just don't see it and
here i am 10
at 10. i just wanted to have a 10-year
renewal but
that got kind of chatter with everything
going on with covet and everything
so i'm still planning to do that because
we want to remarry each other
and you know another thing you and i
talked about was ti's relationship with
deja and after all the changes they've
gone through
how is their relationship today what is
the biggest change that you've seen in
him
i think he's just being a little more
understanding it just
was him you know being too honest and
sharing too much and really what's the
um what's the problem for
ada not so much of any other any other
real
issues like you know she knows that
she's loved to no end and he also
spoke to her apologize to her and was
very sincere about it and he felt like
he didn't
really uh owe anybody any apology
as much as he did her and as long as
she was accepted and forgiving
he was okay with that he knew that the
rest of the world
didn't accept it and didn't wasn't on
his side and they were very angry
but the only thing it really cares about
is what she feels
of course and to hear you say that he's
more understanding i mean
can you give me an example like is there
something that stands out to you
recently
he has a new project that he's working
on and he has
um and he's just understanding more
understanding of like what she really
wants to do
they are trying to come up with things
that she really wants to get into
things she loves and she's trying to
help her
create that that deja thing
he's all into whatever she wants to do
whatever you want to do babe okay
so let's talk about this how can we do
it like he'll call him
like okay so you said he was gonna have
this for me i'm still waiting on it i
need a business plan
i need this you know so he's being very
um open to trying to hear her out
and um understand her you know from a
young teenager
um outlook i love that to hear that
they're
they're working together so does that
mean that they're in a good place
definitely in a good place she's
upstairs she's been staying with us for
the last week we've been having a good
old time
you know she her dad's kicking it every
day
so everything's going perfect i love to
hear that
i want to talk about your other baby of
course zonique
what do you feel when you process that
your baby
is having a baby it's pretty pretty
um pretty awesome right now because i at
this point i'm
really ready to see my grandchild and
and to you know feel this grandma love
that i'm supposed to be getting
and i'm just ready to see her in mommy
mode because i feel like she's going to
be an awesome mom
yeah of course and i i know you're going
to be
the most unbelievable grandma i'm
curious
have you decided what you want to be
called
i am working on it nikki wants me to do
coco
oh i love that do you like that i like
cocoa
i do like coco but i'm you know i'm like
i'm playing around with honey
i want to talk about a huge moment on
this show
where zonique announced her pregnancy
live on the air while your husband t.i
was a guest
i want to know tim who do you think who
do you think this sonogram belongs to
i'm gonna say anybody would need me
it's it's me pop it's me
that's what's that's what's going on in
the mix
what was going through your mind during
that huge episode
well i was just ready for her to get it
out i knew for
maybe a week or two and it's hard for me
to
hide things from him like that he's
gonna get upset if he finds out that
i've been knowing how this long time so
she was like okay okay
i know what i want to do i'm gonna tell
them on the show like okay
and i thought it was cool you know it's
her new platform so
she had him on so i thought it was
pretty cool
he had a real tough time believing that
it was actually
true y'all playing man y'all playing
y'all playing y'all playing now you
but you with y'all [ __ ] you know huh
what did you make of his reaction
well i feel him because when i first
when i heard that she was pregnant i was
just like
because she's never really been like i
want kids or right now
you know so i was just kind of like wait
a minute you having a baby
like you ain't like your only child you
know
you're not ready for a baby but i think
um she is
she feels like you know something that
i'm really gonna have that i
care about that's gonna i'm gonna pour
my almonds too
was it hard for you to keep that secret
you said you held on to it for like two
weeks
yeah it was it was hard because a little
baby things kept coming up and one time
we were playing the game and somebody
said something about some grandma
granddaddy and he was like man
i ain't i got a long time for that i
want to be like no you know you're
you're about to be one right now
but i can't so when zanik was talking to
me last week and she told me
about how when she discovered that she
was pregnant she wasn't immediately
overjoyed she was actually a little sad
but of course now she's in an amazing
place and she's so excited about
everything
how were you there for her during that
tough time whatever
she really wanted to do i'm gonna be
behind her you know and
whatever her decision would have been
and i let her know that and i let her
know that you know
um if she decided to have the baby
that's
what it was going to be you know i would
be there for her i would support her
and she would have she knows that she
has an amazing support system she has an
unbelievable
support system around her and you know
she she gave props to her man
izzy and said that they're doing really
well does izzy have
your stamp of approval yes he does
he does a guy you know he tricks so well
and she as long as she's happy
i just try to be there whenever if she
needs me she wants to talk about
anything
and i think they have a great
relationship they're so loving when i
was asking her you know do you think you
you want to tie the knot do you want to
get married
she had a really awesome response i feel
like i could definitely marry him but
i don't want to get married anytime soon
i think he could definitely be the one
but we shall see you know that's the
thing about getting married you know
you're married you're all the way locked
down
let's see how long the relationship goes
on i think that's a smart
decision i want them to be ready and
because
marriage puts a lot of strain on a
relationship when she's ready to get
married
i'm all for it i wouldn't rush her into
getting married just
for the sake of saying i'm married
because a lot of people get married
and get the voice right after and it's
like
that child if the same child that you
were worrying about being
not having being married to being in the
house with two parents
they're still not in the house with two
parents now because they got married and
they just didn't work out when i had her
i was not married
of course i thought that he was going to
be the man for me and we were going to
be married
and he ended up going to jail and that
went away i end up having another life
i'm
i
created another life but when he was
long i
really made sure nick was you know she
was great i had a job i was making good
money
you know what i'm saying so i knew who i
was i wasn't second
guessing what i was gonna be able to do
for my child whether i had a man or not
i am the man and the one and the woman
of the house
and when i need to be if i need to be i
could be the man and woman of the house
but unless
you know god bless me with a husband so
i don't have to be the man in the house
there
but if i needed to i have that i have
that power i can do it